if you're starting a business or you  have a business room make sure that you  know the difference between want and  need  so many people think i'm going to create  a business based around this thing  because everybody needs this well  everybody needs to stop eating so much  sugar everybody needs to eat healthier  everybody needs to go to the gym but  people don't do any of those things  unless they want to  so don't get delusioned and fall so in  love with your own product or your  service knowing that people need it  because they probably do but just  because they need it doesn't mean they  want it and if they don't want it  they're not going to cut you a check for  it so differentiate the two between want  and need